here we have Toby I tracking technology
it's a prototype that lets you control
display using just the motion of your
eyes here's how it works it uses
infrared sensors that make a 3d image of
your eye then it uses the glint of your
eye to see where exactly your eye is
moving you can use this technology in a
few different ways so they have the game
called I asteroids which has asteroids
coming at your face and you have to use
your eyes to smash those asteroids
before they hate you you can also use it
for controlling a desktop user interface
like Windows 8 metro user interface when
you move your eyes left or right it
scrolls through the screen when you're
reading the text automatically scrolls
up as your eyes go down the page and it
could also be used in the future in
detecting drowsy driving once you start
blinking and getting sleepy it would be
able to notify your car this technology
is just a prototype so it's still a few
years off
you